[Music]
let me suck you
[Applause]
could you please clear the room
[Music]
gotta be careful here
place is crawling with them
what was that what
cover me
guys hey guys
hey guys oh thank God
and we started a community of survivors
y'all come live with us
[Music]
wait how did you know
come on redneck wants us to move into
his community
us
let's go
over here
oh thank God there are others
would you let me date your daughter of
course
oh my God oh my God oh my God
please don't hurt me uh my best friend's
black and I love Jay-Z and uh my
favorite movie is Think Like a Man
she's good come with us stay close okay
what's your name Emily of course it is
what do you think about the police
well I love the third album
I don't have any money I have no money
hahaha
oh my God oh my God thank God you guys
showed up I gotta get out of here
silver Lexus just pull it right up front
and don't scuff the paint all right I
just had it buffed
was he an alien too yep
oh please don't say anything please just
keep it to yourself
oh
thought you had an idea I do
we need to make an app like for a
smartphone an app that all the people
could download and then we make millions
it's just hard to come up with man it's
like catching lightning in a bottle I
already got that you got what
lightning in a bottle really what's the
idea no no idea I got actual lightning
in a bottle no Levi that's just a phrase
I got that dog
lightning in a bottle blip that's crazy
son would you get that some old Chinese
man sold it to me years ago
I mean that's some Supernatural man
all it does is this
I got it
but seriously man
would it be like an app that reminds you
when your favorite television shows are
on no
a bottle
what bottle
the bottle with the lightning in it
you still on that yes
how does it work assistant I don't know
it's the classic lightning in the bottle
you just opened it up
okay you know what you shouldn't have
this this belongs to the military or
something
but that app though no we don't need the
app you've got the goose that laid the
golden egg
how do you know about Honkers
what
August get in on this app idea
you like it
yet he got a goddamn golden egg
Honkers here is the cats pajamas
no please don't don't I want to show you
something whatever it is I don't want to
see it it's relevant I already know what
it is it ain't what you think
well what I think it is is a pair of
cast pajamas
these are for Honkers to wear the what
the Little Neck in there the neck How
You Gonna fit his head
through this with the orange
[Music]
why because you disrespected my roommate
okay
okay it's clear that this is a crazy
house so I gotta go you over here
talking about geese the golden eggs and
Feline sleepwear
Matt Cedric you need to get off your
high horse man
I just thought of a name for you
high horse
[Music]
moving out
please this is the worst possible time
please don't do this
babe
garbage huh
okay now take your garbage yeah sure
you know I find the more garbage in the
can
the better it feels to dump it all out
I suppose that's why we let it get so
full in the first place
so we can start over
here
to fix the copier yes sure sure hey how
did you sometimes things ain't really
broken
it's the way we treat them
it needs to be fixed
[Music]
who the hell are you guys the important
question is who are you Steve
well
if it isn't Mr stand now
Carl Carl
[Music]
you need to find your own little
troubled white boy
I was here first
the copycats
sweep this
foreign
[Music]
[__]
yourself
[Music]
good Lord are you all right
well
I guess sometimes things have to come
apart before we can put them back
together again oh you're a magical negro
too
who you call a negro [__]
[Music]